let's let's talk about rumble
we have this from corp.removal.com
rumble proposes proposes an open source
content moderation policy and process to
improve transparency and put craters
first so
for those that might not be familiar
maybe you're new to politics i'm
assuming it's probably a small
percentage of people most will probably
know this stuff tim one thing this is
exclusive to you released on independent
media
not through the typical channels just to
add to the previous stuff right on
so obviously for those you know youtube
youtube has been big but youtube has
banned people without warning youtube
has censored information they don't like
and they've done very shady things if we
want to have open and honest
conversations we need to be able to be
on platforms that have that are healthy
and robust
so with rumble which is uh well it's
it's how would you describe it how are
you a video hosting service
the way to describe rumble we're
we're a platform that's uh with two
different things both video and cloud
now so we're going to be pushing cloud a
lot in 2023 but we're we're a video
platform an open and free video platform
that's going to protect the free and
open internet as much as possible truth
social is uh that uses rumble
infrastructure it does yeah they're
their entire actually when they opened
up the floodgates when you're able to
come on it was because they moved over
to the rumble cloud and timcast.com uses
rumble's infrastructure for our video
player on the members only section of
the of the show which is monday through
thursday at 11 p.m signing become a
member but all of the hosting the entire
website is built on your guys
infrastructure because there's got to be
we have to build something
that is alter an alternative to silicon
valley's monopoly on the space and it
has to be resilient to censorship it has
to be competitive i think you guys are
so let's talk about what this what this
move was trying to make the rules more
fair better and this helps you compete
but it's also better for the people yeah
so
one this was completely inspired by your
show we you know we took a lot of flack
with our terms and conditions you put it
up there six months ago and i was like
[ __ ] you know this thing hasn't changed
for a long time and it's you know we we
went through a time period of eight
years
um when i came on in january where you
know things changed a lot in
the way we've kind of built our track
record over the last eight years is
based on terms and conditions where we
didn't move the goal posts and we kept
really really sturdy we didn't change
the definitions of certain things
and our track record proved to be really
good we you know we we don't ban for
things that are that don't make sense
and we're not doing what youtube's doing
but
the term said we could ban you any time
we want for anything we want we however
we want we had this conversation a lot
of the rules were very similar it was
yeah with with the exception of all like
the misinformation stuff that youtube
so uh viva and barnes you guys what you
came up with a plan or something or what
happened so it's the same plan that i
talked about with twitter you know five
years ago and with twitter it talked
about being amenable too and then backed
out of the last minute which is you can
create a space that protects a free and
open internet without being bombarded by
trolls and haters and harassers and
stalkers and doctors and defamers you
can have something that is a free and
open space free both from censors and
free from stalkers and the rules are
right there the rules are there in
american law the rules are there in jury
instructions the rules are there already
laid out you're not supposed to have
discriminatory misuse or abuse of a
platform because of section 230 there
hasn't been a lot of us litigation but
there are ways in which you can create
rules that are a desirable community
that maximizes freedom of speech like
right now you can go to rumble and if
you want to look get independent free
information like we did an interview
with dinesh d'souza in 2000 mules we can
only do it on rumble but you can create
a space that is free for those kind of
discussions that you can have heterodox
opinions that you can have heretical
opinions and be completely free to share
those with your community and at the
same time have rules that are not only
consistent with that but also open and
transparent the other aspect of this was
have an appeals process that matters
what frustrates a lot of people is that
they get suddenly banned without notice
without knowledge without means of a
meaningful appeal happened to eric
hunley uh
unstructured podcast and all he does is
just interview interesting and uh
interesting people so the goal was let's
create an appeal process that works and
it's manageable and that's where viva
helped create a lot of those because
he's been through that process knows
other people has been through that
process also make it participatory but
what we mean we've had american
democracy for about 300 years and the
goal is to uh we've learned that an open
transparent participatory process
produces the best result and best
outcomes it's not only about the free
market of ideas it's about letting the
ordinary person participate where we're
talking about earlier that's who often
gets targeted for suspension and banning
on social media it's the ordinary person
that's why these rules are just proposed
rules people can actually look at these
rules and say we see a problem here we
see we think this could be improved
there's a there's actually an email set
up that they can actually email in their
ideas their suggestions their comments
make this process as best as possible
and ultimately have a community and
content creator jury that will help
adjudicate these processes so the goal
is let's create something that will work
for the entire big tech universe let's
create the model chris has been willing
to open source these rules so anybody
can borrow them anybody can copy them
anybody can imitate them this is about
making the free and open internet free
and open again the jury system i think
is interesting mine's implemented
something similar minds.com mind yes
it's so hard to say because something
you're saying it sounds like you're
seeing minds yeah m-i-n-e-s m-i-n-d-s
they had a system where if someone posts
something
that is a violation of the rules they
have moderators if you post something
that's like illegal content like you
know child abuse and stuff it gets nuked
if you post something
and it's like maybe that's violence or
whatever it gets sent to a jury of users
and then they're asked to vote on it and
then i'm not exactly sure how it works
but then they can vote yeah this breaks
the rules
if it does break the rules all that
happens is they put a filter on it that
says not safe for work
anything that would instantly have to be
removed for like law breaking and stuff
is removed no matter what because
that's just law breaking content but as
for the community guidelines the worst
that can happen i believe is they just
put a filter on it where it blurs the
image and then you have to choose to see
it so you don't even get banned for
posting you know hateful stuff or
anything like that yeah you run into the
issue about people posting their own
criminality or or things along those
lines but so full disclosure one thing
robert and i have been working with
rumble for these terms for a little
while but
haven't we don't like rumble because
we're working with them we're working
with them because we like them and i
knew rumble since 2014 when i was just
posting cat videos type things and they
were just a video hosting platform and
licensing agency
um what they're doing now is is amazing
and important because people are getting
shafted left right and center on youtube
they're getting soft censored into
discussing only the things that youtube
will allow them to we've gotta when we
have certain controversial uh figures on
and those are by the way doctors uh i
had to do one interview specifically on
rumble with dr chris a francis christian
because youtube i knew it was going to
happen on youtube um
but other people say like well i want
free speech on the internet that means
running around and saying you know
racial expedition whatever and
that's not what freedom of speech in the
meaningful sense on the internet means
what it means is that you have objective
clear-cut rules that are not going to be
weaponized for political and narrative
driven purposes so you know hashtag
learn to code is not going to be
tolerable when the left says it but when
the right says it it's a call to
violence banning right and so that's
what you have to navigate with with the
internet i think we've done it but yeah
we've created the same rules that for
public squares that exist all across
america they have rules right you can't
go to a local public square and do
pornography do obscenity uh dude you
know try to attack somebody you can't do
any of that so we just took those some
cities these days to be honest i
wouldn't be surprised yes unfortunately
yes you've been to san francisco
hey there you get it at little kids
reading you know book story time you
know surprise surprise but the uh the
goal is to take what those historic
rules have been and apply them to the
digital public square and make it as
transparent and open as part of the
process but people can continue to
partake and participate in this if they
think there's improvements we can make
that rumble can make they're invited to
do so this is the beginning of a
participatory process to return the
internet to its roots of being open and
free
i dig it no it's great and and the the
sort of call it board review or
community review it works when the when
the community doesn't get radicalized
when it doesn't get filtered down
through its own soft censorship and so
you know people who love the community
want to preserve it
they're going to preserve it and they're
going to preserve it so that they can
all speak freely this sounds good but
but how does it work how the how are you
going to implement it and put it into
action who's going to be making the
calls about what is allowed and what is
not so it's a three-fold process so one
is the actual rules themselves to make
them open transparent easily accessible
that's what's being posted uh i believe
now already up there yeah if you scroll
up on uh because if you break a youtube
rule youtube doesn't really tell you
which rule you broke or why or what you
could do for any possible redemption
and that goes to the second part of the
process so we help first design the
rules we're there's also going to be
posting guidelines of how we're
interpreting and applying these rules
just using jury instructions uh using
things that ordinary jurors use every
day in terms of the rules but the rules
are really simple straightforward
accessible they use uh identified legal
terms throughout the united states for
which we have uh have 200 years plus of
history now the second part of the
process was what you're talking about
how does it get adjudicated how do you
get notified of it who decides what role
do you have in responding to it uh what
do you know who the uh the the the jury
pool is consistent of is that a publicly
disclosed list that's what viva took
lead on
yeah
bottom line you have your clear-cut
rules
there's automated stuff for copyright
trademark uh if
other than that if a community member a
user flags something there's going to be
a first review by rumble and if they
determine it's okay
it'll it'll continue there might there
will be flagging for people who to avoid
brigading to to avoid what i suspect
happens a lot on youtube people don't
like your stuff so they just go randomly
and with impunity flag it if people fly
too many things uh that are deemed to be
unfair flagging they'll suffer the
consequences so people it'll ris it'll
create a sense of responsibility will
they be down ranked in the algorithm or
how will their account now get punished
for abusing the system ultimately
suspended in bard if they continue if
they just if they just continuously flag
and wrongly flag content that rumble and
or the community determines is not flag
worthy they'll get strikes to the point
will they get suspended or permanently
banned although even chris has a big
heart there will be no permanent bands
except for egregious stuff it'll be a
year ban if you violate you know over
and over and over again to the point
where you break the rules which are
going to be clear if you don't like them
that's going to be the other bottom line
is the rules are there it's not a
lawless society if you don't like the
rules that'll be your decision but one
thing you can rely on is that they're
not going to be politically weaponized
to go after one side of the ideological
spectrum uh and immunize the other and
you'll be given specific notice on which
rule is being alleged to be violated
you'll give an opportunity to respond an
opportunity to respond to rumble after
that if you don't like it you can appeal
it to the community board the community
board is going to be fully publicly
disclosed it will be content creators
and members that are invested in the id
of rumble as a free speech platform they
will make a review and you have an
opportunity to uh oppose them and even
then if it's a first offense that only
leads to the content being taken
what about sentencing
after you're convicted of breaking the
rules
and then there's a structured process
you have to violate it i think four
times within six months before you face
any kind of
deletion of a channel and even then it's
only for a year time period so four
strikes because you were talking about
strike systems
there's two there's two different
processes so one that we're really
changing here that i really like is the
is the copyright thing we're going to
give everybody an opportunity to take
down the video if there's a copyright or
challenge it before it's taken down
before an actual strike is applied to
the channel and like on youtube you can
get like 100
three or four strikes and your channel's
gone so we're gonna give the creator an
opportunity to appeal it right away
without applying any strikes give them a
12 to 24 hour period
to figure that out um that's on the
copyright side on the
on the policy take side if you look at
the policies they're all related to like
unlawful conduct but
let's say you do a bunch of things that
are that are wrong if it's egregious
then obviously you're not there's going
to be no forgiveness but if they're
if there's
nuance to something then you're going to
be able to come back within a year what
does no forgiveness mean permanent man
yeah well
when we first went through it it was uh
it was permanent bans for people that
break the rules four times within a
within a six-month period but then i
said i was talking to to both of you and
you know i really felt like there has to
be a way in a path to forgiveness right
because
everyone gets forgiven and like either
well even murderers
you can get 25 years after killing
someone and still get let back out and
join them that only that is only based
on whether or not you believe in reform
for the ones you want to reform but in
other ones it's immediately permanent
banning and and you know being kicked
out of society right i suppose there
would be a life sentence you know what i
mean and i think posting child abuse
photos
is should be like a certain like yeah
and that's what we're and that's what
we've come to right so like but we're
like i said these are these are just
proposed we we don't want to make these
changes to the community until we feel
the community is fully on board with it
and this is our first step towards going
towards that um because it is moving
it's the first time we're going to move
the goal posts but i think we're going
to move the goal posts in the opposite
direction and really they're trying to
take their rules and comply with what
they've been doing for the last eight
years
it goes very in line with our track
record the big question i hear from a
lot of people is
ui update update when uh yes that well
it's it's on the ios app now
so you can see the new ui on the ios app
um and the the website the website that
that'll be coming in the coming months
cool
so it's looking good i guess
it sounds like um something that we used
to have in the in the us legal system
called the due process
exactly we don't really have that
anymore we have a lot of freedom of
expression freedom of speech freedom of
press due process of law jury trial
rights all these ideas we've borrowed
from to incorporate in the big tech
space to restore the public square to
the internet so these are the proposed
rules who's going to decide
that these rules and content moderation
is going to be moving forward and are
you guys specifically saying you can't
say this this political ideology is not
allowed this is okay this is not is is
this the process so what we have posted
up there is pretty much the what what
we're proposing right now um and we're
gathering feedback you can email us
there's an email posted there that where
you can
send us feedback and what you like and
what you don't like so we can take that
back but one of the things i really
wanted to do is
you know i i've founded rumble i i've
run rumble but i'm not i'm not a i'm not
a creator that focuses on law i'm not i
don't have a law degree like who am i to
to to really put this together that and
the best thing i could think of is
coming to creators that have law degrees
and understand this they understand free
free speech better than anyone else to
suggest something is there a political
ideology that's off limits like if like
a group signed up you'd be like
like no but i mean it's designed if
you're making illicit content so like
the clan and the antifa tends to make
illegal content but there's no ban on
the clan there's no ban on antifa
there's no ban on anybody i mean like
one of i still think the best
measurement for whether a platform is
consistent about freedom of speech is is
alex jones on that platform alex jones
has had zero problems on rumble that
that's shown there and even when senator
scott from florida came after him
because they allowed rt to be on rumble
rumble didn't change their position so
even when the united states senator from
the state that rumble is partially
located in came after him they they
stayed with it so i was only willing to
invest my time if chris was sincere and
chris was clearly sincere because i've
been uh passionate about this for more
than half a decade i gotta say i'm i'm i
think sincerity is great but the reality
is this is the market opportunity if
you're trying to grow a business this is
how you do it well you imagine uh
take youtube as a specific example where
they have as a rule for content
we we will deem misinformation remove
strike and penalize channels for
suggesting anything that runs afoul of
what the who is saying right now and
bear in mind that the who the world
health organization has that depending
on the year said both a and not a or
both a and b a and b and so
you don't even know what the rule is
going to be for the for the for on the
going forward basis let me tell you i
had a meeting with google not that long
ago and i said
i advise
all young people to start on rumble
because while the audience size
certainly is much smaller your
opportunity for growth is much larger
you're more likely to find it not you're
going to find an audience faster
and you're less likely to have your
business destroyed
due to arbitrary rules and i said i've
got to be honest with you i don't know
what the rules are and i read them every
day it's remarkable because i have seen
people get banned for one thing and not
something else i have seen a prominent
left-wing podcaster call for an act of
terror and he got a strike
is that it i know another guy who had
his entire channel deleted because he
did black comedy that's it he broke no
rules he was monetized
and they and they just delete his
channel outright with no warning with no
strikes purge
this was my own like i've been on
youtube before i was really focusing on
rumble but since 20 whatever 14.
this was my initial experience with what
i call youtube chicanery it was the alex
jones deposition video all i did as a
lawyer total cringe stood on the roof of
my house with sunglasses breaking down
in alex jones deposition i didn't know
that aj was persona non grata on youtube
i do it the video gets like close to a
quarter of a million views then they
pull it or they demonetize it then they
pull it and then i notice i got a term
of community guidelines violation for
hate speech so the video's gone all
that's left is when you click on it
community guidelines violation for hate
speech and
i it was and then then it comes back on
two weeks later and it gets re-monetized
senator rand paul was speaking on the
senate floor c-span published the video
and youtube took it down unbelievable
youtube you are psychopaths
and then let's also be honest here if
there's a big brand a big business or
the corporate media they get the front
door at youtube they get walked right in
they get pushed in the algorithm the
trending videos that's the videos that
that of course are connected to the
biggest businesses that are connected to
their google advertisement uh businesses
and revenue so so there's already a
clear bias if you're an independent
media creator and i wanted to bring this
up with you guys when you're on youtube
there's no way the algo
algorithm is going to be playing you any
favors unless you have big money that's
why rumble is such a such a good
alternative as well as the other
alternatives out there but but who
decides what's going to be in the
algorithm last time we talked about let
people see what they want to see if
they're subscribed to something let them
see it um
how is the algorithm going to be shaped
to what rumble's going to be showing
people how you know how will independent
creators fare in that kind of ranking
system so the way it is right now it's
just chronological so there as far as an
algorithm goes it's chronological by
time um i think the important thing to
do and i think ian mentioned this last
time is have have these algorithms open
sourced yeah um if we do deploy an
algorithm right now because it's
chronological there's really nothing to
open source
isn't there a challenge though that if
they know how the algorithm works
they'll game it
there there is um so like the way you
can game a chronological algorithm is
just keep putting content out constantly
and flooding the feed so like that's
that's one way to do it but like
isn't that on the cur is it on the
viewer if they're if you're flooding the
feed don't follow them so you cut back
on who you follow this is how this is
how we were running social media 10 15
years ago um but we all went towards
these engagement based algorithms that
amplify content based on engagement and
that changed everything and changed the
games they figured out they can skew
things they figured out they could do
things um i think if you keep it
chronological it's helpful and but that
doesn't solve the problem for
for discovery
so in order to have discovery of
creative independent creators you're
going to need to provide some kind of
algorithm and some kind of some kind of
mechanism and what we want to do is have
that discovery like
kind of like in a tick-tock format where
you can kind of go through and scroll
through scroll through content
and open source that algorithm where
that algorithm will be based basically
on you know how much you like a video
how much you dislike a video and whether
or not you have a preference for that
video so we're working on something like
that right now because discovery is
super important um to help find creators
and we should have something hopefully
by the end of the year that's it's
already launched right now but it
doesn't have an algorithm in it the
algorithm is very basic it's based on
likes and the ratio of likes that's it
um and then the other way is through
search is just making sure your search
is uh
we would like to open source that as
well and making sure that you when you
find something you understand how you
place the search you place in the search
base right now based on time the excel
the the velocity of views and the the
the the context of the video so the
characters the titles the descriptions
it's very simplistic right now and if it
does become something more complicated
then open sourcing that is i think
critical
but uh the discovery portion is the part
that we all want to solve for because
once you nail that and you give
viewership to small creators then you
really have something special what what
about your uh
rumbles api is it gonna are there gonna
be an option for people to uh i don't
know
develop on top of the software embedding
it incorporating it so we already have
that so rumble player which is you know
going to be part of this rumble cloud
business that we're building um
is has open apis that you can use to
search find and embed into other
platforms
cool
sounds like everything's there huh yeah
not yet not yet still lots of work
there's a lot of work so we're done we
won
i never understood what algorithm is
more relevant than like and uh subscribe
retention rate no people watching a
video and liking it i can see from a
monetary perspective engagement even if
it's negative
youtube had the problem where every
video started with the guy screaming
smash the like button for 30 seconds and
they turned it into a game and then all
of a sudden all the top videos were just
videos of people saying smash the like
button but that'll that'll self-correct
when people start downvoting that crap
because it's no longer fun to watch
people wouldn't even click it so there
were there were people like they're
they're literally just videos where a
guy for a minute it's like smash the
like button the camera's like zooming in
and out and it would get 500 000 likes
and people who don't like it just don't
click it the issue it dominates the
issue with that as well is like it will
self-correct from what we're seeing in
the data but the problem with it is is
that
you know you're going to have a platform
that has a genre of videos that that
everyone likes and then a new person
comes on and it's a completely different
genre they're looking for and how do you
figure that out
i will say one thing the fact that
youtube i said it before robert will
pontificate on this one day when youtube
takes down
uh videos from doctors on the basis of
medical misinformation i consider that i
consider that to be practicing medicine
without a license that youtube is doing
arguably unlawful in my humble opinion
hashtag your information absolutely yep
i mean for me coming from a political
space the rand paul video removal was
just
mind-boggling and they're giving out
wrong medical advice that is leading
people to be hurt their assault on on
one particular medicine and labeling it
an animal medicine
has hurt a tremendous amount of human
beings who rely on that medicine for
other things remember when uh with the
roe v wade leak
uh vice put out an article about how you
can take animal medication and use it to
induce abortion yep and then someone
created a meme let me see if i posted it
i can maybe it's on my instagram because
i thought people might not be uh
appreciating the story that the same uh
agency which said you're not a horse
yada yada
at some point later on they're talking
about
what's the word not even homeopathic
alternative remedies um
it's it's bizarro upside down to induce
abortion uh abortion through uh horse
medicine
so yeah that's that's the level where
we're at and they're promoted in the
algorithm they're shown to everyone you
search a topic they talked about it
they're going to be shown to everyone in
the general public yeah it's it's called
horse pill theory
and uh so it's from the political
compass on instagram
and like horseshoe theory the left it
shows uh
the the motherboard article talking
about taking horse a veterinary medicine
to induce abortion and then it goes to
the right and it's it's uh the horse
paste and in the middle it's bojack
horseman i just thought it was a
brilliant meme
it's like this is what you get in the
modern era i guess but they didn't ban
motherboard for recommending people eat
horse medicine please don't eat horse
medicine yeah
did i wonder if the fda did they put out
a warning on that i mean the fda is
being sued because of their tweet about
uh ivermectin so the uh deservedly so
but i mean when you have people like dr
peter mccullough you're talking about
some of the most well-respected medical
doctors in the world that are now being
censored like we're going to do an
interview with them we're going to have
to do it on rumble we cannot do it on
youtube no we're not we're going to
gleefully do it on rumble so that i can
actually ask the questions i want to ask
same thing with doctor
christian we talked about this with the
twitter story that
these twitter employees are listening to
elon musk talk and they're oblivious to
the fact that he's there because of them
because of their political bias because
of their incessant need to silence
people they don't like they have created
republican elon musk youtube is doing
the exact same thing
they are they're they're taking people
there may be someone who says like like
uh you vivo you're like i'm gonna do a
video on alex jones in his in his
deposition they ban you imagine a new
creator who's not political and they say
oh i'm in law school i really want to
talk about this they get banned they go
guess i go to rumble
now what are they what are they doing at
rumble they're seeing nothing but all
these big prominent political creators
who have been censored everything
youtube was trying to silence now front
and center for those people to see they
are pushing people into the information
they claim they want to suppress it's
remarkable how insane they are well
they've done that to alex jones the all
the efforts to de-platform him have just
led more people to be curious about what
is he saying that everybody's so scared
of him and has led to more people going
to infowars more people uh going in for
a store more people being engaged than
almost ever before their efforts to sign
in the irony is i mean alex was
seriously considering about retirement
after 2016. he'd achieved extraordinary
number of things over a quarter century
and then he decided to sign wage law for
law fair against him and decide to try
to take him de-platform him and he's the
kind of guy who doesn't go gently into
that good night you know and so he is
here today louder and stronger than ever
before because of their efforts to
destroy him and not just that i will say
having spent some time on the interwebs
a lot of people are now realizing that
alex jones was right more often than usa
today and when he says things
hyperbolically
he's still
i don't want to throw my wife under the
bus but when uh one of the stories the
conspiracy one of the theories
uh was that 5g towers are gonna mind
control you and i was like oh that's
that's garb when when you i when you
understand that by that term it just
means interfere with sleep patterns you
know it could interfere with uh
a form of of your cognitive abilities
it's not control in a sense but when you
realize that it's hyperbolic but well
relatively accurate on some things um he
he he would often take the story and
then just take this little dot and
stretch it out
so
he would dramatize it in order to get
attention in the rest but people pay but
people would ignore the underlying i
mean turned out they were trying to turn
some of the frogs gay you know i mean i
mean it's that kind of well that was
that so so that's that i i love this
story because the the frog's gay thing
was was alex talking about atrazine i
believe it was a pesticide right was it
and they said that it was interfering
with the endocrine systems of frogs all
that meant was the frogs were becoming
deformed or male formed and then alex in
his ranch it says they're turning the
freaking frogs gay and people people
literally believe that he was he was
being literal when he said that i just
no he was just doing an entertaining
rant it's much like trump that the uh
his audience doesn't take him literally
they understand the proverbial reference
to it but his deeper truth that you
can't trust institutional people in
power the people who seek power like
michael malus theory are
disproportionately going to be dangerous
people and we have to be constantly on
the alert for him but i mean it turned
out everything he warned about you know
that they're going to use a pandemic to
help lock down and strip us of our civil
liberties well we've experienced that
that
unique things might happen with
elections we've experienced that that
the mass censorship was coming through
big tech control we've experienced that
i think there was also something about
uh medical microchipping and
a youtube moderator is watching this
video is like oh i'm gonna ban this
video right now can i do it can i do it
now can i do it now barnes keep going
keep going well it's just legal
you know that's the beauty of reporting
information lawsuits going back to rand
paul this is public sourced information
so if you are saying something in
congress if something is said in court
it cannot be the subject of a libel
lawsuit or anything else if you're
fairly and accurately reporting what was
in there and so there's all this
information and yet now we can't even
talk about things that are happening in
congress or happening in courts on
youtube that's a level of insanity
when the rand paul thing happened
i had posted a video it got taken down
and the weird thing about it is
the video was still there someone
messaged me and like hey your video's
gone tim and i go into my studio on
youtube and i look and i'm like it's
right there
and then i hover the mouse over it and
the mouse doesn't change you know like
when you hover over a link it turns into
the finger pointing it didn't change i
couldn't click on anything it was like
an image and i was like what and then i
found the urox i tweeted or something
and i video had been removed and i was
like they tried making me think that it
was still there something like that
happened it was weird and there's a lot
of dirty tricks that we don't even know
a lot of things be happening behind the
scenes that we're not even privy to that
they're implementing right now that we
don't even know about there's medical
doctors there's medical studies that are
being censored and banned on big tech
social media platforms that's when you
know they jump jump the shark we're
going to change all that my friends and
i think we're winning that's why i keep
pointing out that luke's on a billboard
in times square so as ian so is michael
malus because i just i was like we got
to put people up on this to give a big
middle finger to the establishment
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you